[Musica]
nel 2013
esce con spike jones questo film per lei
il protagonista vi ricorderete forse
theodore si innamora di una voce
samantha questa voce un assistente
virtuale che apprende evolve simo le
emozioni e buon theodore alla fine
scopre che in realtà si sta innamorando
di altri 8 mila individui e addirittura
di questi appunto se ne innamora di 600
a sua insaputa ma perché parto da qui
parto da qui perché la fantascienza
certamente un grande potere immaginifico
ma nella realtà il rapporto tra noi e
robot tra noi e gli assistenti virtuali
vi dico un po diverso noi siamo in grado
di realizzare dialoghi complessi come io
sto provando a fare con con voi noi ci
emozioniamo esattamente commisto
emozionando adesso io facciamo dei
ragionamenti complessi e tanto altro
ancora
e poi ci sono i robot i robot sono delle
macchine sono degli hardware dei
dispositivi che hanno al loro interno
software e algoritmi molto potenti ma
tali sono
e lasciatemi prendere a prestito una
citazione di una grandissima studiosa
del rapporto tra uomini e robot che si
chiama margaret boden e che è una
professoressa di scienze cognitive
dell'università del sussex che ribadisce
che cosa che i robot sono degli
strumenti per quanto speciali e che la
responsabilità di come usarli di come si
debbano comportare e io aggiungo di come
progettarli dipende tutto da noi
e con questa premessa entrò nella vita
quotidiana se ci guardiamo intorno siamo
circondati da oggetti che funzionano
anche grazie all'intelligenza
artificiale magari non ce ne rendiamo
conto nelle nostre case ci sono gli
smart speaker la torretta di amazon di
google a cui chiediamo per esempio di
attivare con un comando vocale la musica
è sempre di più utilizzeremo questi
comandi vocali più di oggi ad esempio in
auto ma l'oggetto che più di ogni altro
all all'interno il concentrato di
intelligenza artificiale che cosa è il
nostro smartphone nel quale troviamo
le app di social media di video
streaming la il navigatore la fotografia
digitale altro ancora
la tecnologia rivoluzionaria che
sottostà all'interno di questa
intelligenza artificiale un nome si
chiama machine learning che significa
sistema di apprendimento automatico e
come funziona io non ho mai scritto una
linea di codice eppure vi dico che è
importante sapere come funzionano le
cose funziona al contrario della
programmazione tradizionale che è
prevedibile parte da dei dati delle
regole dell'ingaggio di programmazione
delle risposte
il macello era in funzione al contrario
ha bisogno di tanti i dati di echi
etichette risposte attraverso delle reti
neurali che sono dei modelli che
associano dinamicamente tutti questi
dati sputa fuori lasciatemi dire appunto
dei modelli e questo a volte viene
considerato una black box eppure da
luogo a tutti quei servizi così potenti
le aziende io lavoro molto con le
aziende le aziende come utilizzano il
machine learning dal 2016 in poi hanno
iniziato ad esempio con di chat bot
o devo carbotta ad automatizzare i
contatti interazioni frequenti per fare
cosa soprattutto per trovare delle
efficienze mantenendo i livelli di
qualità alti per prevedere comportamenti
dei clienti pensate al calcolo del tasso
di abbandono per evitare che gli utenti
abbandonino un servizio o peggio ancora
un brand oppure oggi se ne parla
tantissimo per digitalizzare parti o
interi processi operativi viene
utilizzata molto nei processi di frode
texon di riconoscimento delle frodi
oppure ancora ne abbiamo sentito parlare
tantissimo netflix amazon i sistemi di
raccomandazioni predittive viene usata
tanto per personalizzare sempre di più
servizi e contenuti in base alle nostre
caratteristiche per orientare spesso i
nostri comportamenti di acquisto
bene questi dispositivi questi servizi
alla fine sono sempre così intelligenti
funzionano nel modo in cui noi ci
aspetteremmo
e beh la risposta è no perché a volte
usiamo il vocal bot il ciatt non
funziona come noi ci aspetteremmo
l'esperienza decade
e questo perché avviene a volte sentiamo
anche delle voci un po robotiche non
proprio come quella soave di samantha e
questo perché avviene avviene perché
quei sistemi non sono stati progettati
mettendo al centro gli utilizzatori
finali non sono stati progettati per
essere comprensibili e interpretabili da
noi utenti finali e questo è il grande
principio del buon design è uno dei
primi principi di buon design che
enuncia il guru della user experience
colui che ha dato il nome user
experience che si chiama donald norman
già dalla fine degli anni 80 con questo
libro che vi invito a leggere che si
chiama la caffettiera del masochista e
dunque serve un approccio sostitutivo in
cui l'intelligenza artificiale si
sostituisca a noi ebbene no io vorrei un
approccio collaborativo in cui gli
algoritmi l'intelligenza artificiale ci
aiutino si avvicinino all'uomo e
partiamo dai buoni esempi che già
esistono
guardiamo per esempio quando facciamo
una foto quando facciamo una foto senza
che noi ce ne accorgiamo oggi scattano
degli algoritmi che ad esempio
bilanciano in real time e luminosità
contrasto e tanto altro ancora e noi
lasciamo il nostro sforzo cognitivo a
questi algoritmi potenti che fanno il
mestiere meglio di noi
noi però rimaniamo in controllo per che
decidiamo noi chi sa chi fare la foto
decidiamo noi se fare tante foto se
cancellarle
se aggiungere degli effetti e quindi
farci ri aiutare dall'intelligenza
artificiale spostarli sui social in
questo caso c'è un bilanciamento tra il
controllo
la decisione che noi manteniamo e degli
alti gradi di automazione così come
avviene quando utilizziamo il navigatore
io sono riuscito a perdermi anche nel
centro di pordenone pure riattivato
google maps e lo ammetto google maps è
piuttosto che waits da quando esistono
sono dei compagni di viaggio ai quali
affidiamo completamente il calcolo del
percorso più veloce che fa l'algoritmo e
lo fa molto meglio di noi ma noi rimane
la scelta di dire ok dove vado come ci
vado aspettami fermo e cerco il
ristorante il ri chiedo aiuto
all'algoritmo per trovarmi il ristorante
none nella zona in cui mi sto muovendo
cosa pensavano le aziende che hanno
realizzato questi servizi così potenti
hanno messo al centro l'utente finale
hanno adottato un approccio che mette al
centro l'uomo
e questo che cosa significa significa
iniziare ad osservare le nostre attività
degli utenti finali nel loro contesto
d'uso fin dall'inizio del processo di
design di progettazione e poi
continuando incontrarli costruendo dei
prototipi prima ancora di aver
addestrato qualunque motore di
intelligenza artificiale facendo delle
simulazioni e dell'esperienza futura
perché noi utenti finali
possiamo testare capire e andare così
progettisti possono migliorare questa
interazione e con i servizi di
intelligenza artificiale diventa tanto
più importante raccogliere i feedback
dopo quando questo sistema in linea
perché quando noi interagiamo con uno
strumento tendiamo a modificare il no la
nostra interazione in funzione di come
progettato e quando iniziamo ad
abituarci possono scattare nuovi bisogni
pensate di nuovo la fotografia digitale
e ice elfi i produttori di smartphone
non avevano in mente selphy quando hanno
iniziato a creare gli algoritmi della
fotografia digitale
poi noi che cosa abbiamo fatto abbiamo
girato il cellulare abbiamo iniziato a
fare selphy e quindi adesso i produttori
di smartphone fanno degli studi per
osservare gli utenti nei contesti d'uso
diversi come quelli che vedete qua per
capire come andare ad adattare la
fotografia e renderla di alta qualità
quando le persone fanno selfin adesso
voglio farvi sentire un'esperienza di
successo un'interazione tra un vocal bot
ibrido ma capiremo perché ibrido un bot
e un consumatore un'esperienza che
funziona quando una signora sentirete a
breve cerca assistenza stradale perché
ha avuto un problema con la macchina
l'assistente virtuale in grado di
comprendere e gestire rapidamente le sue
richieste di soccorso stradale in causa
possa aiutarla
cosa vi può aiutare sono rimasta a piedi
quasi un carro attrezzi
posso inviarle il soccorso ma per
organizzare al meglio l'assistenza è
utile sapere che problema a il veicolo
non parte mai tra camminavo con le mappe
a piede mi dispiace per il guasto
addio subito la richiesta di soccorso
prima di procedere dica per favore il
numero di targa
allora il numero di targa è catania
vicenza 4 6 6
milano seguita perfetto ho trovato i
dati del suo veicolo nei nostri sistemi
procediamo con alcuni dettagli e il suo
recapito
qual è la marca e il modello del veicolo
la marca è una bonus renault
il veicolo è renault modus cece renault
modo governo adesso dica per favore il
suo nome e cognome
francesco è importante avere l'indirizzo
esatto in cui si trova con il suo
veicolo sia bisogno di tempo per
controllare l'aspetto allora io mi trovo
a catania prove centro via giordano
bruno
attendo solo un attimo le confermo che
la sua richiesta di assistenza e stata
registrata e saremo sul posto il prima
possibile per qualsiasi necessità
la ricontatteremo grazie per aver
utilizzato il nostro se allora avete
sentito un'interazione fluida vera
questo è una vera interazione avvenuta
intorno al 2017 2018
questo è un servizio attivo peraltro
tutto italiano un'innovazione tutta
italiana in cui l'esperienza fluisce in
cui non ci sono interruzioni in cui la
signora riconosce avete sentito la voce
guida così la chiama capisce che un bot
ma si lascia guidare perché perché c'è
stata una progettazione che ha tenuto
conto di come quell'utente si comportava
fin dall'inizio e anche dopo questo è il
solo una delle prime interazioni quando
è stato messo in linea questo sistema
poi è stato raffinato ulteriormente e
avrete sentito anche i battiti di una
tastiera nelle micro pause che aiutano
l'utente a come dire capire che c'è un
elaborazione da parte del botto
esattamente come avviene
nel dialogo tra persone e qui c'è
un'altra forma di collaborazione
un'altra sfumatura di collaborazione tra
uomo e macchina perché interviene l'uomo
in gergo si chiama il bo tel per un
aiutante del bot che ha una sua
piattaforma ascolto un piccolo audio
l'intera conversazione e quando per
esempio nel caso in cui l'algoritmo non
arriva nel riconoscere il linguaggio
perché può avvenire che ci sia un rumore
una targa che è molto difficile da
riconoscere in autonomia dagli algoritmi
l'uomo interviene roma interviene e
l'utente finale percepisce solo quella
micro pausa e va avanti
questo che cosa comporta perché
l'intelligenza artificiale ha bisogno
della user experience di questa
centralità dell'uomo perché così
possiamo creare dei servizi che
funzionano che hanno un bilanciamento
come nel caso della fotografia del
navigatore tra il controllo la decisione
che deve rimanere a noi uomini e anche
alti gradi di automatismo questo crea un
circolo virtuoso perché mi dà fiducia
perché vedo che riesca a raggiungere il
mio obiettivo come la signora che
abbiamo appena ascoltato e quindi mi
porta ad adottare quello strumento e
perché ancora perché io percepisco
un'utilità un vantaggio c'è un utilità
reale perché risolve il mio problema è
evidentemente questo per le aziende che
investono e lavorano in questo modo
porta un valore di ritorno
in conclusione è importante a mio parere
un approccio che avvicini che faccio a
collaborare algoritmi e intelligenza
algoritmi intelligenza artificiale uomo
non sostitutivo ma perché per migliorare
la nostra vita per aumentare le nostre
capacità e perché no anche lasciarci
degli spazi di creatività laddove noi
riteniamo che possano essere utili
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]